we are here at CES 2024 and this is my
favorite time of year and I am so hyped
because right now I'm in the TCL booth
now TCL is the official TV partner of
the NFL which brings me to the reason
that I'm here right now I actually have
a guest for today's video Charles
Woodson the legendary NFL Hall of Famer
I'm going to be taking him through the
tour of the TCL booth and showing him
all of the awesome televisions and you
guys may have seen my review of the 98
in that I recently just did oh yeah it's
here and we're going to check it out so
come on let's go find Charles all right
Charles we are here at CES at the TCL
booth on the field here I feel like this
is kind of your home tur yeah I'm kind
of at at home on the field when I see
all the lines and the numbers it takes
me back to my playing days but actually
being out here amongst all the tech I'm
out of place so you need to help me out
a little bit all right we'll go from
your Turf to my turf there we go I like
let's go let's go check it out there's
so much fun stuff to see I can't wait
all right we're cruising through the
booth here I'm in all and I don't know
where my eyes should go next real
question though we're not going to go
there now but are you a gamer to play
games at all I'm not a gamer oh great my
son is a gamer so maybe you can help me
learn what he's doing so you've learned
a thing or two though yes okay so this
is the QD mini LED TV wall like this is
just so beautiful is that actual water
no it's just a television oh okay I me
that's the crazy thing is how expansive
the technology has gotten also for
consumers too like the price point has
come down like these things are actually
affordable now yes they want this to be
accessible to everyone so
the pricing is key sure yeah it's so
beautiful and look how realistic it is
yes I mean imagine this like in your
home uh you know what I am imagining it
and I'm going to have some in my home so
I can't wait it's so great I love it so
this is kind of the start of our tour
it's the entrance to the booth but
there's something else really cool that
I want to show you it's a it's a movable
couch a movable couch yeah you'll see
you'll see okay I'm following you I'm
following you all right so this is
actually a 98 in television which back
in the day like I would have thought
this was tooo large but I I recently
just got one in my living room and it's
surpris wait we're moving oh we are
moving we are moving oh my goodness they
say we don't need seat belts but
apparently we do but I love this demo
because it's kind of showing you that
even if you think that the TV might be
too large for your living room no matter
the distance that you are from it it
still looks crystal clear and it is such
an immersive experience yeah well what's
amazing about it is that you do think
that 98 is too big but now that as I see
it in contrast with its surrounding it
doesn't seem like it's too big yeah
seems like it's a per perfect fit for
any room you hearing like a 98
television like years ago you would
think that's like something you would
only see he like where you going to put
it exactly but now they're so thin
they're super lights and obviously like
the viewing angles too I mean we're
sitting pretty close and it's still is
crystal clear all right let's see what
else is in the booth all right let's go
oh my good oh here it is this is the
115 in QD mini LED this is the world's
largest one this is what I've been
hearing about now the thing that is so
fascinating about this is this has
20,000 local diving zones which is going
to give you super clear picture the
contrast and like just the colors I mean
look at this it is it honestly feels
like real life well all I'm doing right
now is imagining myself sitting in my
theater room and looking at that let's
just take a walk around it first because
I this is the first time I've seen this
and it's surprisingly thin such a
massive TV I mean the thing that they've
done you know with televisions nowadays
is just mind
I think I have to get this one all right
there's more to see all right let's go
all right so I wanted to show you the TV
that I have in my home I have the 98 in
version of this the best part about this
too is it does have like a game mode as
soon as I turn on my Xbox or whatever
console I'm playing it'll automatically
switch the refresh rate everything is
just set up so that I can start gaming
so it's it's really cool so you love
this
television let me blow your mind with a
fun fact okay TCL on Black Friday
decided that they were going to give
away a mill million doll worth of 98 in
televisions if there was a 98 yd
touchdown return a 98 yd touchdown and
guess what was there one somebody did it
zon Holland from the Miami Dolphins
returned an interception back 99 yards
for a touchdown and TCL gave away a
million dollars worth of Television well
I so excited that all those people get
to enjoy it because honestly This TV has
been it's literally been a game changer
like I keep saying that but it it has
just changed not only being able to
watch content uh gaming everything and
it's just been so such a fun addition to
the home well we've been talking about
how real everything looks on this
television how scared are you when
you're playing Call of Duty when
somebody's aiming that gun right at you
it's a little scary cuz I move like a
massage chair like right in front of it
and then I'm just sitting there I mean
it's like a scene of a movie I mean I
just sit there and just game and it's
just it's great I don't think there's
any massage chairs in the v of fil so
yeah that's we're we're we're alone in
that well I got to get the Call of Duty
because I want to experience that on on
this as well oh do you I do I got to get
it I got to get it I believe that might
be possible today today I think so
you're going to show me how to you're
going to show me how to play we'll see
please do okay we got more to see all
right bye TV I'll see you at
home all right so this is the new
flagship QD mini LED TV and this ranges
from the 55 to the 98 that we already
saw and what's really exciting about
this is it's going to be really great
for consumers because this could go up
to 2400 nits of brightness which
especially if you're in a well lit room
it's going to be super bright it also
has
1,500 local dimming zones and this is
really cool see this is actually a great
example so if you see all of those
blacks like the lights on the panel
actually turn off so it really gives you
that true sense of the depth and the
Blackness and the color so I was I was
wondering what the dimming zones meant
and so you just explained to me so
anytime I see any area where there's
black they turn completely off exactly
it's literally exactly what it means
local dimming so this is uh entry level
and so what does that mean to the
consumer more about price point but also
what I love about tcl2 is like the
quality is I mean obviously like you're
looking at these compared to some of
these other ones and it still looks so
fantastic still got great quality yeah
so no matter what level you come in that
quality is going to be there but it
might be a little lighter for your
pocketbook we love that we love to see
it love okay we've got more things to
see come on man let's go let's go we've
moved on from televisions but these are
so cool so this is tcl's next paper and
okay pick this up and tell me what you
see like it looks a little bit different
than a normal tablet right yeah it does
not so much uh not as much light yeah
emitting from the screen and it's almost
like you're looking at a picture like a
print out so they're using this layered
LCD technology to make it so there's
like no glare like you can take this
outside in different conditions which I
I love reading and like using my
computer at the pool but it's usually
too sunny so with this that's going to
give you such a better viewing angle and
everything you'll actually be able to
see it I've seen a lot of things and
I've used a lot of different types of
tablets but this is on honestly like it
it's it's super Innovative and it
actually is really easy on your eyes
there's also two other modes on here so
we have the next paper mode which it'll
turn it all into like black and white so
it looks like it's an e-reader and then
there's another mode where it'll give it
a little bit of color so you can still
watch videos but it filters out all of
the blue light so it's it's really great
if you're you before you go to bed if
you want to watch something and you
don't want to kind of trick your brain
into seeing too much for that blue light
I think TCL tried to think of everything
I think they have they have they have
this is so cool I love all right so we
just saw the next paper on a tablet now
it's also coming to the phone check this
out phone too yeah this actually going
to be coming out later this year so this
is not a prototype like this is this is
something real intangible this so it
does all the same same features wow
that's so strange to see it's so like I
don't even know what I'm looking at
right now what what am I looking at
right now that's inredible w wow I'm
looking forward to checking out this
Tech so fun should we take a selfie on
it let's do it we the first to do this
yeah we the first to take a selfie on
this phone
it ain't even out
yet so what's a great TV without Great
Sound this is their 2024 lineup of sound
bars and subwoofers and you've got lots
of options I can't wait to experience it
we're going to right now actually this
is going to be the best of the best
wow okay this is going to be cool so we
can see what each thing sounds like the
TV TV plus the bar or the bar so right
now this is just the sound bar just bar
which sounds so good TV plus bar
[Music]
oh yeah and what's cool about that is
it's actually using the television as
the center speaker and then it's able to
use the left and right from the Soundbar
so here's just the
TV I mean it still sounds really good
well let's go back I want I want the
other sound though let me get the other
sound let me get
that oh man yeah come on so good I mean
can you imagine imagine watching a game
on this like it would actually feel like
you're there yeah I think you know
you're watching the game and you see
these guys running to each other and all
of a sudden it comes from back here and
you you might jump you feel like you're
actually in the game like that sound is
amazing I'm not going to lie this
actually sounds better than I thought it
was going to like this has exceeded my
expectations what I know I can't I can't
hear you what' you say so great no that
is awesome man I love that can they even
hear us yes probably
not it's cool hey this sounds like a
Vegas nightclub this where we at we're
here so I think it's finally time to do
some gaming I don't know what we've been
waiting on I we're waiting on you well
let's do it let's go okay it's finally
game time you're at home over here I am
at home actually what's really cool
about this too is you can change the
game picture mode so again I play a lot
of first person shooters so I would keep
it there but depending upon the type of
game you can change the Picture Style to
fit your needs and it's also got Shadow
enhancer so you can see the different
levels here so there's so many different
game types and with this it just really
lets you kind of customize to exactly
what you like I think that I need to
coach you through are you going to
you're going to let me play and all
you've been talking about is gaming well
um I'll say afterwards I'll play but uh
yeah so this we're going to be playing
it looks like we're playing a mission in
the campaign so uh to aim we're going to
hit here to shoot oh okay we actually
we're throwing a molotovs right okay oh
my God I'm lost okay here you go just
just go just go
okay keep going all right reload reload
hit the square hit the
square I'm dying no it's okay it's okay
system overload hey now now I'm scared
Aim
Shoot get him okay he's a friend don't
shoot
him yeah yeah you can aim down sights
with the trigger right here okay oh God
you're going to get hit with a grenade
move here wait let me see just real
quick let me got help help going help
this is how you need to aim down the
sight this is going to help you oh no oh
no no we're okay we're dead we're dead
you're doing good though okay okay okay
for let me think let me
think reload reload reload Square reload
you're Square sorry you're right but
you're getting shot so just
run you got a kill you saw that yes huh
we're going we're not going there there
get him okay that is your second kill
I'm super impressed okay hide behind
something I could help myself Jesus two
kills he's a pro he's a natural that was
hard I think maybe you might want to
think about joining an orts League I
need some practice okay you're CL I
really need some you know what I'm going
to get me call of as soon as I get my
TVs I'm getting Call of Duty that was
that was intense it really was so it's
pretty amazing because Call of Duty is
my favorite game and TCL is the official
TV of Call of Duty so like this pairing
is it just couldn't be more perfect that
is awesome so I've been in your world
for the past I don't know hour and a
half let me take you back to my world
again oh no y oh gosh okay let's go
we're in my world look at this thing
look at that you know what that is don't
you I I do it is a football I do you
told me something a little while ago you
said that your sister threw the ball to
you once and it was the worst thing she
had ever seen she said it was the most
embarrassing thing the most embarrassing
I don't even think that we posted the
video because it was that bad wow so
what we're going to do today this is for
you sister okay all right this is for
you Jenna we're going to teach you how
to catch okay all right it's going to be
real simple all right I don't want you
to have your hands in front of your face
cuz in case you miss it I don't want it
to hit your face okay so I'm going to
have you just put your hands to the side
but I'm going to have you make a diamond
okay all right so when this ball hits
your hands it should somewhat fit like a
diamond so be ready to catch it okay
don't just leave your hands there you
actually are going to catch it okay all
right you ready yep let's go
oh that was terrible the important thing
is you caught it we're going to try one
more time okay okay okay now I'm ready
this is it what's your sister's name
Jenna Jenna for you oh no
that's that's what I'm talking
about man just caught the ball if you're
a TCL partner you got to learn how to
catch because they're a partner of the
NFL look what she just did should I try
to throw it or why not hey why not okay
let's try you going to put your fingers
here you want to have a couple of your
fingers on this thread cuz that's going
to help you spin it all right all right
and all I want you to do is try to keep
that elbow here in front know you boom
nice Easy Motion okay all right got it
okay I'm going to go out for a pass you
got here you stay here okay I'll go out
for a pass it's going to be set hut I
need you to just put it right here in my
basket all right all right ready set hut
oh god oh oh that was actually good all
you got to do is get it to the receiver
I'll do the rest this was so much fun uh
I look forward to hearing the review of
your new 115 in absolutely I can't wait
your soundar and your new career as uh a
new Esports Legend well your new career
as a football player let's do it can I
have that it's yours I got to practice
it's yours you'll never be the same